however in today's video I want to do a
very basic video on how to set up your
computer to get started with several nos
framework so what I'm going to do in
this videos first I'm going to show you
which terminal I'm using then I will be
installing some packages that you need
in order to install several s and also I
will install atom that is my default
text editor this one of the videos that
you will want to watch if you're
starting with several s also if you want
to get started and you don't know how to
configure your AWS account on how to
create it go and check the link I'll
leave you in the cart and also in the
description box below these two videos
together we left your environment ready
to get started you will have work in the
realest framework and work in AWS
account so now let's go to the computer
screen and let's get this rolling so now
I'm in the computer and the first thing
I want to do is to install the terminal
I'd like to use because in mark I don't
like the Mac terminal so we'll install
this I turn to and for that I'm going to
the web page where item is an inertia
storm loaded and then I run the
installation process as any other Mike
package if you want to see how I
configure my item because I don't use
the default configuration let me know
and I can make a video but that is
pretty simple now when my item is comfy
its downloaded and installed I'm going
in unload Adam because Adam is a cool
text editor that I like to use I will
download it and when it's ready
I will also install it and get it ready
after Adam and the terminal are
installed then I will go and install
homebrew that is a package manager for
Mac and with that I will install node so
I just follow the instructions in the
webpage and I continue everything that
it says there and it installs homebrew
and with that I can then install
different packages that are needed in
order to stop several A's or any other
development environment so I like to use
homebrew
you can also get note from other places
but this is the way I like it
so after the homebrew finished updating
and getting configured then I will
install node using it
it takes a while so I will speed this up
for you because it doesn't make sense
for you to watch the whole installation
of my different packages that homebrew
needs after it's done then we can go and
install node which just type brew
install node and as easy as that node
comes on its installed brew works for a
lot of different libraries that you
might need so you will enjoy using it
forum for other things as well and this
will download the latest version of node
into my computer after it's done
then we are ready to install service
Corollas is a node library so we will go
in to install it as a global package in
our computer so we just do MPM install -
treat herbalist and we download several
last packet in our computer as a global
nori that we can use from anywhere when
that's done then we are going to
configure our credentials our AWS
credentials in the serverless package
that we just downloaded and for that you
need to have an AWS account if you don't
have one and you don't know how to do it
just follow the instructions that I live
in the card or in the comment box below
so we follow the instructions that are
in the in the circulars page that is to
setup your provider credentials and for
that there is a lot of information that
you can follow or wishes can do one
magic line I leave you all these links
in the description box so you can find
them but it's a simple as that that is
the line that we want to use to
configure our credentials or less config
credentials then the provider and the
secret so when the credentials you need
to go to your AWS account that you
created Oh - I am and then go to your
user security credentials and you can
create a new access key so you follow
the video that I recommended in the card
you may have already these CSV file
downloaded so you can just open that and
you don't need to do this step when you
open that file you will see that there
is a an API key and a secret so you just
need to put that in the line and in this
case I will just do service config
credentials providers
and that's all then if you open your
file the aw screenshots then you will
see that the credential is configured
there then we can verify that everything
is configured properly so we just can't
create a new service project and we just
do that so let's create as always
template AWS no J yes and then the name
of the project
it'll be my first SLS project and we can
just open that in Adam and we are going
to configure an API gateway so we can
test this I will put an API gateway here
this is not a video about how to make
several list projects but I was just to
show you that you can't just apply this
after to verify that everything is
properly configured so I just making a
very simple API Kay away and then we can
deploy if everything deployed then
everything is properly configured and we
can go to our AWS account uncheck that
we have the lambda and we have the API
gateway and we can also run that URL
that API gateway is giving us to make
sure that there is something really
returned so I will speed up the
deployment and we will go just to the
end when we get the service information
which is copy paste that URL and we see
that there is something coming back
I want to remove the service we just do
is let's remove and even remove
everything from the AWS account so our
$1 account will be clean you don't need
to do this this is just because I want
to show you how to clean your
environment after running some tests
this was the video for today I hope you
liked it if you did give a big thumbs